several new measures to protect American
security and prosperity China's pattern
of misconduct is well-known for decades
they've ripped off the United States
like no one has ever done before
hundreds of billions of dollars a year
were lost dealing with China especially
over the years during the prior
administration China raided our
factories offshore our jobs gutted our
industries stole our intellectual
property and violated their commitments
under the World Trade Organization to
make matters worse they are considered a
developing nation getting all sorts of
benefits that others including the
United States are not entitled to but I
have never solely blamed China for this
they were able to get away with the
theft like no one was able to get away
with before because of past politicians
and frankly past presidents but unlike
those who came before my administration
negotiated in Fort for what was right
it's called fair and reciprocal
treatment china has also unlawfully
claimed territory in the Pacific Ocean
threatening freedom of navigation and
international trade and they broke their
word to the world on ensuring the
autonomy of Hong Kong the United States
wants an open and constructive
relationship with China but achieving
that relationship requires us to
vigorously defend our national interests
the Chinese government has continually
violated its promises to us and so many
other nations these plain facts cannot
be overlooked or swept aside the world
is now suffering as a result of the
malfeasance of the Chinese government
China's cover-up of the Wuhan virus
allowed the disease to spread all over
the world instigating a global pandemic
that has cost more than 100,000 American
lives and over a million lives
worldwide Chinese officials ignored
their reporting obligations to the World
Health Organization and pressured the
World Health Organization to mislead the
world when the virus was first
discovered by Chinese authorities
countless lives have been taken and
profound economic hardship has been
inflicted all around the globe they
strongly recommended against me doing
the early band from China but I did it
anyway it was proven to be 100% correct
China has total control over the World
Health Organization despite only paying
40 million dollars per year compared to
what the United States has been paying
which is approximately 450 million
dollars a year we have detailed the
reforms that it must make and engage
with them directly but they have refused
to act because they have failed to make
the requested and greatly needed reforms
we will be today terminating our
relationship with the World Health
Organization and redirecting those funds
to other worldwide and deserving urgent
global public health needs
the world needs answers from China on
the virus we must have transparency why
is it that China shut off infected
people from Wuhan to all other parts of
China it went nowhere else it didn't go
to Beijing it went nowhere else but they
allowed them to freely travel throughout
the world including Europe and the
United States the death and destruction
caused by this is incalculable we must
have answers not only for us but for the
rest of the world this pandemic has
underscored the crucial importance of
building up America's economic
independence reshoring our critical
supply chains and protecting America's
scientific and technological advances
for years the government of China has
conducted illicit espionage to steal our
industrial secret
of which there are many today I will
issue a proclamation to better secure
our nation's vital university research
and to suspend the entry of certain
foreign nationals from China who we have
identified as potential security risks I
am also taking action to protect the
integrity of America's financial system
by far the best in the world I am
instructing my presidential working
group on financial markets to study the
differing practices of Chinese companies
listed on the US